Kelly Ripa and Mark Consuelos may just
have set the record for the longest
family vacation ever to us and they said
it would it I said it wouldn't last
et can confirm that the couple has been
quarantined with their kids in the
Caribbean since the start of the corona
virus pandemic not gonna lie
sounds pretty nice to me I'm the
luckiest woman in America
Kelly opened up about the fams decision
to stay put during a virtual town hall
meeting with ABC employees on Thursday
according to people kelly explained that
three days after they arrived on the
island the entire world changed quote i
hate to use the word stuck but we were
we decided to stay where we were and
kelly confirmed that by the time things
shut down all three of their kiddos 22
year-old Michael 18 year old Lola and 17
year old Joaquin were all with them but
her parents and Mark's parents who were
set to join them didn't make it out in
time which makes this whole emotional
moment from live with Kelly and Ryan
back in April a whole lot more relatable
I want to hug my parents I miss hugging
my parents so what was supposed to be a
two-week trip ended up being a whole lot
longer and Kelly says she and Ryan
Seacrest's went right back to work
hoping it would bring some normalcy
under very unusual circumstances Ryan
and I both decided it was better to do
the show
have you heard things overheard things
learn things about the kids and the
family that maybe you weren't privy to
prior to this isolation we needed
together all of us in many years the 49
year olds who has been co-hosting the
daytime show from her vacation home also
opened up about what it's been like for
the family to be away from their loved
ones and their home in NYC admitting
it's all pretty unsettling I've been
most grateful that at least I have my
adult children with me it's been a great
benefit for us to have each other to
have our viewing audience and just to
hear Brian Chapman's voice in my ear our
director first thing in the morning it
just normalizes everything as
abnormal as it all is Kelly and Mark
celebrated their son Michaels virtual
graduation from New York University this
week and the Riverdale star kinda-sorta
alluded to the whole vacation gone wrong
thing in his caption writing we know
it's not what we all expected but we are
so grateful to be all together on what I
know must seem like the longest family
trip ever
as for Kelly she shared some throwback
pics of her firstborn writing and just
like that you graduated college I feel
so bad for my son Michael who is was
supposed to graduate in a couple of
weeks back in April Kelly opened up
about Michaels canceled graduation on
live it was such a big talking point in
our house and you know because he not
only is there graduation a it was at
Yankee Stadium but then his film school
they have a separate graduation and that
was supposed to be at Radio City and
again these are small problems
considering that so many people are
losing their loved ones and very very
sick but it's just it is what it is you
know what I mean it's like I'm Michael
by the way is not bothered
that's when Ryan swooped in with a
pretty sweet backup plan not that it's
any substitute but perhaps we can
conduct a mini ceremony or him here
maybe yeah maybe I mean that would be
nice
these two really are just the cutest
co-hosts in daytime TV of course
Ryan joined Kelly in 2017 at the time he
told et that Kelly is magic we've known
each other a long time I think that
every day that I see her she I will text
her sometimes you know how great she is
in that I'm in awe of what she can do
and I don't know if it's a krishi ated
what a skill it is to do this show and
be a friend to strangers every day on
television and so she impresses me with
her ability to do that and with kindness
every day I mean I'm like I'm gonna cry
I'm about to cry I've worked with a lot
of people and she just has that magic
[Music]